chris
how are you good man
um i actually was not expecting to be on
here but um i guess just click the link
to hop in
yeah true i just thought it was like a
like a podcast on here so i could just
view it from here all right but i guess
i could um
how do you not get
stuck into a slippery soap slope with um
like having uh an abundance of women
like so your problem is you have too
much poon
yeah like and i i almost get like
distracted
so it's funny i had i had jason momoa's
younger brother calling a few weeks ago
and now i got chad thundercock's younger
brother chris calling in going i've got
too much poo i don't know
all right so okay so what's the problem
i've got a magic wand i can wave it to
solve your problem what does that look
like
um just focusing more on like myself and
like how to because i want to be
successful in life and i want to
figure out what
i'm good at and figure out what i really
love but it seems like i almost don't
even make
time for myself if that's how old are
that
i'm 22. and how many girls you got in
rotation
like six right now
and you're banging them all
yeah
yeah dude if you're spinning six plates
and you're intimate with all of them
on a regular basis
you're you're never gonna get anything
done you're just scattering seed you're
just like
that's all you're doing
right i mean you're gonna have to get
rid of some of them if you want to
allocate some like there's 24 hours in a
day right you generally sleep eight of
them you probably eat like an hour hour
and a half of them you know you've got
your miscellaneo like you know but if
you're spending
your days with six different checks
you've created your own problem and then
you're like why do i have this problem i
don't understand
literally
actually let me ask you this if
uh you were 22 right now um
what would you be kind of like doing
right what would you be doing right now
oh dude if i could go back and talk to
my 22 year old self he wouldn't listen
probably
but if you would listen or or at least
you know give me his ear for a few
minutes
i would i would tell him look you know
uh time flies really fast like before
you know it like
i think back to when i was 22 hanging
out with my boys at you know 2 30 in the
morning racing on the sport bikes you
know just so all hours of the nights you
know ditching cops just just being like
you know young men
and
while that was fun and that
feels like that it happened just just
yesterday
i would have been better off using more
of that time
uh
making something out of myself
developing more competency skills
figuring out how to make bank sooner
right so actually so i'm in school
and i'm working like a nine to five
right now
but i also feel like i'm not doing
enough if that makes sense what's what's
nine to five what are you doing
i work on cars at the moment what do you
do so um at like so i when it's the
school
school year
i usually have classes in the morning
and then
i go to work at like three and then i
work till like nine
okay i'm just working on cars so a
mechanic or like what do they have you
doing i'm a technician so i i'm i'm not
certified to do anything but i
essentially know how to do everything
yeah so they have you do all the [ __ ]
jobs i remember doing that in high
school that's when we had drum brakes
with asbestos on the pads i'm kind of
past that point i don't really do like
[ __ ]
asbestos would go up your face
yeah i i'm kind of past the the pitch
point but like i'm not doing like tires
or like oil changes or anything like
that but
um yeah like for whatever reason i feel
like i'm not doing enough
like yeah well well you weren't because
wayne smith here at 22 was shooting f-14
tomcats loaded with thousand-pound bombs
off an aircraft carrier
right so can you be doing more [ __ ] yeah
dude of course you could um
where do i
what do i do like well what do you want
to do when you're a grown-ass man do you
want to run a custom car shop do you
do you even like working on cars
no not really it's just good mo it's
good money right now okay well here's
the difference between you and me so i
figured that out when i was about 15. i
remember i used to i used to have to
walk and then take the bus it took me
like an hour each way to get to the shop
that agreed to do like
um i think it was called co-op at the
time where you'd get like three hours
placement and he would get like the free
labor so i would do the oil changes i
would clean the shop i would you know do
the drum brake cleanups the spark plug
changes and [ __ ] like that
and it's like i figured out at like 50
and i'm like [ __ ] this i'm not doing
this for my rest of my life i like cars
i love cars i still love cars i mean
[ __ ] the cover photo is my r8 i've got a
mclaren i'm looking at motorcycles again
like i'm doing stupid things with like
you know high-powered vehicles
so
but i don't need to suck in all the
toxic chemicals and you know
expose myself to get electrocuted on a
battery because i lean on it the wrong
way or [ __ ] you know suck in a nasty
[ __ ] when i could just make money and
enjoy you know the byproduct which is
you know the actual drive
right so i mean like you have to get
serious about
figuring out what it is that you want to
do with your life and if you're 22
and all you're doing is banging chicks
you're probably at some point gonna
knock one or two of them up and you're
going to end up being you know in a
situation that could be very problematic
for you so it's like
you know make sure you don't get a
disease make sure you don't knock
anybody up and get yourself you know
sorted on a proper path that's aligned
with what you want to do when you grow
up right
do you want to run a business you want
to get a degree and become a doctor or
lawyer or surgeon something like that
because i mean if you want to make money
which i'm assuming you do yeah
absolutely
it's it's either professional
designation lawyer doctor accountant
surgeon whatever you know where you can
make a few hundred thousand dollars a
year i mean you're still going to be
somebody's [ __ ]
what about social media
what about it
like what if i you want to be a social
media influencer yeah what if i did
something like that
i know it sounds crazy but like if
because i don't want to work for anyone
man i don't i don't want to be anybody's
[ __ ] and okay i mean you look at these
influent influencers and they're making
like a ton of money okay um
you know that i just released a course
on entrepreneurship right it's called
the school of entrepreneurship
i did not know
so the course is closed right now um
it's gonna reopen again in august it's
about it's probably going to be more
than a thousand bucks to get in because
i'm adding a lot more content because
i'm adding webinars now with guys that
are
explaining their business how they got
into it why it's an easy lucrative and
fun business versus heart annoyingly
frustrating and then all the details
around that ecosystem
so anyway pin below in the top comment
get on the list so that you'll be
notified when that comes out because if
you want to run your own business like
if you want to be a social media
influencer you need to get good at
creating content like
you're a good looking guy you're going
to photograph very well they're not
going to have a hard time finding good
photographs of you but do you live a
captivating life and it's and it's kind
of a like
it's it's a weird thing because i have
to use social media
but
i see other people using it to like
excessive extents
where it's like three four times posting
a day and it's like
look at all my [ __ ] all over like i get
it i get it but you have to have money
to have that [ __ ] so most people that
you see
as
social media influencers
with the cars and the girls and the jets
and the bikinis like the dan bilzerians
of the world and [ __ ] like that
you're gonna have to have done something
significant before you're gonna have
that audience follow you like the only
reason why
people follow guys like gianluca vacci
you know for example like you know that
guy's like a 52 year old dude he's got
like a 21 year old girlfriend he just
had a baby with her
dances he's a dj he's the italian guy
he's a [ __ ] entrepreneur he looks
jacked he's covered in tattoos that guy
i'm not familiar with him but he made
all of his money before he amassed
whatever
like he's got an amazon show now right
he's got something like 5 million
followers i don't know what the count is
but it's in the millions now
right i mean if you want to be that guy
then there's years of work that lead up
to that that mean that you've got to
make some money to have some impact and
be influential like even the athletes
and
the movie stars like the rock or you
know if you have like a favorite athlete
you know that you follow there was
years like decades of work that led up
to them you know getting a instagram
following or social media following into
the millions
is it valuable of course it's valuable
because whenever you say
hey guys check out my new
pancake syrup you know maybe the rock
will offer like a pancake syrup for his
big ass stack of pancake day right right
people will buy that [ __ ] up like it's
going out of style right so of course
it's valuable like people pay social
media influencers money to place their
products it's mostly the instagram ass
models where they're all like holding a
bag of tea and it's yeah
but now you have like the
like the male tic talkers where you know
they'll like make videos of themselves
dancing and like they'll get like
millions of views and they actually make
it like if you want to be a dancing
monkey for the entertainment clubs out
there you can do that i'm not going to
judge you i'm just not going to watch
your [ __ ] there's some funny guys on i
don't blame you i don't want to make
money man
well
making money is one thing but making
money in a way that you enjoy making
money is a totally different level true
right
anyway i've given you loads of time so i
appreciate it
so your homework is guys get on the uh
list below
for when the
school of entrepreneurship course
launches again you're going to want to
get in i just wanted to let you know i
did buy your book and i read it it's
really great and helped me thank you and
please if you've read it leave a quick
review on amazon just let go what value
you got thanks man appreciate it all
right thanks hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha
you'll get 10 off on your first order
there's also the option to use the
subscribe and save model where regular
shipments will be sent over to you on a
regular basis and that gives you a
little bit of a discount and your
supplement facts are always broken down
over here thanks for watching i hope you
guys have an awesome day and again check
out that link it's pinned in the top
comment below in this video peace out
you